[Music]
everything dies
looking for me surprise
what's going on everybody welcome to EA
plate 2019 and I'm so excited to talk
about apex legends here at EA play on
professional eSports commentator Alex
golden-boy Mendez now everyone at
respawn has been working diligently and
making apex legends the best battle
royale game out there we've got some big
updates that's right that's right I like
that like that baby bring that energy we
got some exciting details to share on
apex legend season 2 including a brand
new weapon a new mode an improvised or
an excuse me and improvise you hear me
I'm improvising an improved battle pass
a reveal of the 10th legend coming to
the arena and so much more so let's jump
out of this dropship dive right into the
hot zone
take it away Jay thanks golden boy I'm
response community manager Jay Fischetti
as you can see we've brought Kings
Canyon to life right here at EA play
we've even got all nine current legends
here to help me bring you some of the
season 2 updates that you've been
hammering for we're gonna introduce you
to our newest legend after the show but
for those of you at home don't miss your
chance to jump into our legendary hunt
event check it out
beyond is upon us prepare yourself
the legendary hunt has begun legends can
compete to enter an all-new apex elite
cube complete challenges for exclusive
cosmetics I could do this all day
earn XP and battle past boosts and find
all new exclusive skins in the in-game
store only the strong Dolfina and slow
for a limited time legends who place in
the top 5 of any match will earn the
right to join the apex elite queue I
need some help over here
solid copy there they will have the
opportunity to test their skills I need
some ammo against the most talented
legends in the game
the legends protest is from the same
additionally legends can complete
legendary hunt challenges to earn
rewards like the epic master of the hunt
bloodhound the wolf pack g7 in adult
days along Mesa and hunt down to wins to
score the exclusive legendary teamed
beast triple take posting the goats and
you shall be rewarded opening fire
during the event all battle pass owners
will receive the free legendary honored
pray our 301 hit level 15 on your battle
pass and you'll also earn the legendary
night terror race you know what I look
like
come find me every day legends can also
earn an entire battle past level for
your first top 5 finish of the day thank
you for the fun fight and we're doubling
down with our first ever double xp
weekend one moment from June 7th to June
9th earn double XP on both your base and
battle pass progression throughout the
event be sure to keep an eye on the
rotating store for new exclusive
legendary hunt cosmetics the sky has
opened and gift
and drop in as the legendary hunt won't
last forever
good luck legends
that's the Hans begin
[Music]
that's right until June 18th you can
jump into of the legendary hunt our
limited time event that features the
debut of our elite Q exclusive
challenges you can unlock and some
killer skins and more also this weekend
is double xp weekend so there's lots of
great reasons to jump in the community
really brought it since this event
launched and it's awesome to see the
best Duke it out back to you golden boy
thank you so much Jake Thank You Jay for
that appreciate it alright I'll season
one who's ready to talk about season two
I like that so you know hey listen I
play this game every day it's one of my
favorites and I did this like right
before the show started that's how
that's how much I play this game and you
know I'm gonna jump back in when we
finish up but first I do want to talk
about season two we've got the first
details here and joining me we got drew
McCoy in the house ladies and gentlemen
drew we've been so patient for that
beautiful beautiful content what do you
have for us today well it's coming okay
first and foremost Dante is coming
tonight you've heard of here first so
season two it's coming July 2nd and it's
called battle charge
all right so battle charge will be
coming out what can we expect though
when this new season drops yeah so as we
announced when we launched the game
we're taking a seasonal approach so
we're trying to cram as much into the
launch of season 2 as possible with some
other stuff along the way but what you
can expect from the launch is a new
legend I do weapon a new way to play the
game okay perhaps a map event and a lot
of this has been done through a lot of
feedback from community we're also
changing up some of the meta balance of
weapons to try and buff up some of the
weaker weapons and bring a lot of cool
stuff in the game okay alright it's a
lot it's a lot we're gonna talk about a
good portion of it here but let's talk
about that sweet new content because
season 2 is bringing a new weapon to the
fight and today we're excited to show it
to you so let's just go ahead roll the
clip show it
care package touching down they usually
carry their platforms Al's down here I
am taking fire friends I pay the north
[Applause]
your ignorance meets your end
Bonita good job me a new season strong
work
Oh
[Music]
we can't
making contact with enemy
[Music]
Xzibit I'm here you're not there you
have it the old star man I remember
getting slapped by this gun in time
falter though pretty excited to see this
one making it to the fold in the arena
seems really powerful so tell me more
about its place in the entire weapon
loadout for apex legends yeah so the
health stars knew it's coming launch of
season 2 it's actually a care package
weapon because it's so Opie it's just
amazing it's like the master for the
crater it's uh it's incredibly powerful
yeah and being a care package weapon it
doesn't use any existing animal on the
ground so whatever you get with it is
what you got I also noticed too it
shattered through doors yeah I can open
doors so like Bailey's grenades and al
star Wow okay so that is pretty sizable
now what other changes are gonna be
coming to weapons cuz I and this may
seem very nerdy but I'm a huge fan of
hop-up so I'm all about Prowler with my
my switch fire that's that's my jam yeah
what are you bringing me yeah so I can
mention there's gonna be some meta
changes to the weapons we're trying to
bring up some of the weaker weapons and
then yeah there are two new hop ups
coming not really gonna say what they
are yet you guys got to wait for season
two but there is a chance that maybe a
me mobile weapon named after an African
country is usable is usable yeah okay
perhaps alright perhaps I mean that is
yet to be seen well that's good for your
reality alright cool so we're starting
out hot with that l star light machine
gun we also have the battle pass and you
know when you guys first spoke about the
battle pass you said that it was a
learning experience what's different
this time around for season two yeah so
we've been listening to community a lot
season one didn't quite launch as well
as we were hoping the content was fairly
underwhelming for players so we've been
taking that in we've been getting all
sorts of data from people buying skins
to what they equip on their characters
or weapons and so we've we've we've
taken this learning and put it in a
season to battle pass so first off the
bat it's challenge based now instead of
essentially time-based so you'll get
daily and weekly challenges and they
stack if you don't play for a while so
you can come back after a month and
try and knock them all out in a weekend
and level up really quick ultimately
this does mean levelling level 100 is a
lot quicker than in season 1 we're also
getting rid of all the badges and strat
track that trackers taking up space
throughout the leveling process and we
are inserting three new entirely new
content types
into the battle paths which we will talk
about later and there's a lot more skins
in that and there's gonna be enough
crafting metals by the time you hit
level 100 to craft your very own
legendary of your choosing all right I
like that okay a lot of value for that
battle path
yeah that's that sounds very exciting
all right and now you know we're talking
about apex it's got some pretty sick
skins what skins you have for me today
yeah so like I mentioned I think our
skin game is being up pretty
significantly you can see that with the
Wraith skin and specifically from the
legendary hunt event but we got four
legendary skins in the battle pass so we
have two character and two weapon so for
caustic he's got the Prince of Darkness
skin and for octane we're doing the Jade
tiger I think we're yeah I can see
there's a Prince of Darkness right there
and then there is a skin for the
Spitfire called the Intimidator and the
r3o one is getting two skins actually
there so the iron rampage at level 100
okay and then there's a golden version
as well oh man do you see that by the
way that's sick I look insane that looks
insane alright now another question that
the community is having they're just
dying to have answered new ways to play
elite q was awesome yeah I think it's
like one of the coolest additions for
apex legends what else yeah so when we
designed apex legends we really wanted
to have kind of a competitive core to it
this is a game that's meant to be played
over hundreds of hours and mastered
really deep learning experience and so
the elite q is our first step towards
getting to a higher competitive stage
okay and so season two I'm really really
really stoked to announce we have a
ranked mode coming ranked mo yeah all
right
so rank mode you'll progress through six
tiers if you're good enough you will cap
out if you are garbage tier like myself
yeah don't worry we'll be wit division
together yeah you and me buddy
yeah wood wood free I think wait three
yeah yes it goes from bronze all the way
up to apex predator and it's using a
special matchmaking for each of the
tiers so the higher you get you'll
probably have some longer matchmaking
times but it's because we're trying to
find the best possible match for you and
then throughout the season you'll be
hopefully gaining tiers and then at the
end of season you'll get rewards based
on where you ended Wow
to show off for the next season ranked
mode come into apex legends yeah it's
gonna be honest that's sick alright
alright alright
I am be honest with you I'm gonna be all
up in that it's gonna be sick
I can't wait I am legitimately concerned
as I mentioned there would be the first
wood division player which isn't even in
it or plastic division plastics good
yeah that's gonna hurt but dude I thank
you so much for sharing all these
details man guys drew ladies and
gentlemen for the respawn team all right
now here's the thing I'm a lifeline mane
he's just fat him you are to respect
that any lifeline Mane's in the house
flap my mane all right but I might
change from the new season drops that's
right because J give the people what
they want we want to know who is the
10th legend joining the arena
what do you have it's my pleasure golden
boy well ladies gentlemen the moment has
arrived the 10th legend joining the apex
legendre's arena is Watson to help us
get to know our latest legend a little
bit better our team put together this
touching illustrated short let's check
it out
my dearest Natalie as I write this
letter it's the middle of the night in
late summer an hour ago
you cracked the equations necessary to
power the force field
he showed me up tonight my magnificent
daughter and I couldn't be happier or
prouder of that I always knew you were
special but never did I thought that the
little girl who taught her stuffed in AC
multiplication tables grow up to master
quantum laser mechanics
I have assured the syndicate that the
modified containment force field will be
operational in a month's time and it's
all thanks to you
and maybe just a doddering old fool
trying to hold on to moon liebe a little
while longer before he loses her to
adulthood but I do see you I see this
strong brilliant wonderful young woman
you've become
and I know when the day comes that I'm
no longer with you we are going to be
just fine
the games will be brilliant because you
are brilliant my daughter can and will
do anything she wants in this life
because she is the smartest woman in the
frontier shoot em the - mocha pour
toujours papa
[Music]
I did it oppa I hope whatever you are
you're cheering for me ladies and
gentlemen
joining the arena and joining me now we
have three gentlemen who brought her to
life Griffin will and Tom thank you so
much for joining us here Wow
so about that I mean Bible comes from
the chat man cuz that was just that was
just that was the feels right there hit
me rice frightened but Griffin we'll
start with you but you're one of the
legend designers and I'm curious on the
approach that you guys took toward
making Watson a character that has
impact in the arena so Watson really
started as a conversation between a
friend of mine and I who he's an
engineer and he has this really
methodical interesting way of taking
really complex problems and
systematically solving them and so I
kind of thought what would it be like if
we took the sort of the defensive
complexity of Apex and introduced a
character that could really create a an
ecosystem in which you can survive the
really aggressive third party meta all
that stuff so the the idea behind Watson
really is that if you if you plan and
you sort of adapt to the environment you
really know the map and you work closely
with your team that you can really
create these strong defenses that that
people are gonna really have to think
about in terms of how yeah they push on
you and that sort of thing so that the
current meta of I hear a gun fire and I
hit it as hard as I can you know with
Bangalore Wraith octane all of those
we're trying to sort of bump that meta a
little bit and make it so that this this
more Stan's RTS kind of play style has
breathing breathing yeah try to provide
like options for the players yes yeah I
want to be able to play that hyper
aggressive approach whether you're
running like a composition that contains
like a typical one which would be like a
pathfinder Wraith and a lifeline for
that support yeah you can you can play
India
composition like this they kind of
counter yeah one another so that that's
that's gonna be really fun we're gonna
dive into the abilities and everything
that she does because let me tell you
it's insane now as far as the look and
feel my favorite part about excellent
apex Legends is that the characters the
legends themselves they stand out when
you're looking from far away you see the
silhouette and you know exactly who it
is that you're about to engage with what
were some of the complexities in
bringing a character like Watson to life
yeah so it's a collaborative effort you
know got out Heath and Sam animation
Department everybody kind of works
together we were given a specific set of
skills that she would be using abilities
from Gryphon and that's kind of all we
had to go off of so we had to he did a
great job of like bringing it all
together giving her a sort of a grounded
aesthetic using she had to look like she
was using electricity and stuff like
that so with rubber gloves and the coils
and the wires and pushing her silhouette
at the same time making her stand you
have to be able to read who she is from
different distances from the from there
you can really go in and sculpt all the
details out and work with the animators
to really bring her life give her
personality and everything that she does
with her abilities and that - yeah and
there's some really cool stuff there as
well every every part that Watson she
takes out an item in her kit
it's actually like on her person oh yeah
see it happen yeah and those are all
very meticulously designed by the
concept artists and then and then
modeled out in 3d so yeah it's all
functional that's great in the in the
world yeah so now you get to the to the
gameplay the look but the story you know
cuz you got to hit us in the fields
right like super hard and you just did
that
Watson's backstory who she is let's
let's dive deeper yeah that was kind of
different from the way we usually do
things because usually that's very
collaborative and we're creating the
character at the same time all the
different departments and we're working
together
Watson was different she was already
designed and and drawn when I got her
and one of the great things about
working at respawn is is they they
encouraged us to create characters
our non-traditional and there are
characters you haven't seen in video
games before and to kind of branch out
and see what else you know what other
people have the people can we represent
out there and so Watson is a very
different character than I've ever seen
in a video game at least and everything
is based off of what these guys created
I mean it's all every single part of her
backstory is connected somehow to either
her abilities or her look and now
something that kind of stuck out to me
so am I correct in assuming that Watson
played a big role in the arena itself
yes so Watson and her father actually
invented the ring okay
and so she grew up in the arena
literally in the arena and when they
were building it and we're gonna start
to you're gonna see with Watson and
moving forward we're gonna start to
build the lore of this world a little
bit you're gonna find out who created
the games they mentioned the syndicate
in there so we'll talk about the
syndicate down the road your build more
and more of a universe yeah which is
great so she's in here so all the
legends must know her oh yeah she was
their kid sister basically she was
always hanging around the arena and if
she got to know all the legends and got
to watch all of them she's not a
mercenary she's not a soldier
you know she her roles of support and so
she everybody loves Watson she's the one
person that could probably unite all the
legends together cluding caustic caustic
respect sir she's a scientist okay she's
an engineer okay like what wrong word
for cotton yeah I don't know if
constable likes anybody okay that's
that's fair well yeah that's cool I mean
blown away by this character so far now
I mentioned before we're gonna talk
about the abilities because when you
revealed these to me I was floored
jaw-dropping in a lot of people online
were kind of like guessing mm-hmm as to
like what it would be and I'm very happy
to see that a lot of them some some had
the right idea but for the most part
what she's capable of doing is
ridiculous so let's talk about the act
of first thing defense is yes so the the
Watson has more interrelated abilities
than probably any other current
character we have you really need to
understand how they all interact the
fences you can place 12 nodes and you
can use these in any permutation you
part of why we sort of went was that her
being such a brilliant electrical
engineers because we really want to
reinforce both mechanically and
thematically how creative the player can
be with these basically we're just
giving you free rein to place these
however you want and figure out and the
players they like I just saw right now
don't know if that was intentional so
the when your teammates go through its
yeah it's off so I'm found and they run
through the gate there's a gate
deactivate yes oh so there's a lot of
different interactions a lot of
different ways that you can interact
with the gates with other characters the
ultimate is we call it an interception
pylon it shoots down bombardments
incoming grenades stop Sark star spam
and it charges your team shield and also
if the Watsons cooldown is slower when
she's away from the pylon but when
you're near the pylon it supercharges
your your tactical so you get fences
faster so if you drop it down it's uh
it's a it's a permanent structure until
it's destroyed and that allows you to
build these large fortresses very
rapidly you can use that for defending
for flank control on offensive squads
for going up on a tower and fencing it
off the Pathfinder and then the passive
is that ultimate accelerants give you
your ultimate 100% ultimate charge and
so if you save up ultimate accelerants
over the course of the match that allows
you to place more pylons and it means
that you don't have to play
conservatively as watson as long as you
save up ultimate charges you can keep
moving with this with a highly mobile
squad you can play offense defense
support however you feel like the fences
and the pylon are most effective to
whatever comp your plan well you're
telling me here is that lifeline mains
do not need to continuously hold
ultimate accelerants anymore we that was
that was we felt like we needed to a
choice that's right we did it people
finally cuz everyone's like really mean
to me if I don't like use the old takes
out it's not fair oh wow so that is that
is that is ridiculous across the fences
you get pinged as well yeah so if any
enemies cross through the pense the
fences it pings your entire squad so
there's a situational awareness element
to them as well Wow if you know this is
why I like she grew up in the arena if
you know where all the choke points the
edges of the exits are you can set up
fences they
you'll know exactly when it enemy yes
I'm even thinking about like
compositions and how like it could work
out you know maybe for any Gibraltar
mains out there maybe you find a little
no one cheered for that feels bad man
maybe there's like a little little
synergy there that King Kingdom created
there's a lot that can be done with
these fences and being able to block off
certain chokes yeah it's I think it's
really the big sort of the ceiling is
how creative people can get with it and
I'm really excited to see what people do
with it and from the from an art
perspective here you know they're very
distinct they stand out what were some
of the challenges in making sure that
these fences really like when a player
saw him they knew they knew exactly what
it was not to kind of catch him off
guard so to speak to make it really
really stand out in the arena yeah again
silhouettes everything you got to make
it stand out and it has to look like it
lives in the world that she's something
it's something that she can use and that
lives on her body as well she's able to
pull it out and she's able to bring it
out and you know create a creative
fortress basically and it has to read so
we had concept artists working on every
little detail and the modelers as well
and we had to test it out we tested out
we play it in game or in house and make
sure it reads well and these guys do a
tremendous job of it Jim like I need
like a post with electricity like it was
between the two yeah and they just they
create really cool stuff with just that
kind of vague hand-wavy yeah description
about it it's clearly been thought out
this this this legend is gonna be
incredible I can't wait to play watts
you guys excited Watson that is nutty
all right well again very much looking
for right now today we've covered a
bunch here we've seen a new weapon we've
gotten a new mode the latest legend and
the new battle pass for season two so
let's recap all the amazing apex Legends
action that we've seen here today
surprise
[Music]
like
your town is in
[Music]
I'm not gonna let you off that easy true
what was that what was like well what
was that you saw the giant thing on the
screen and the eyeball what was that
carat weight tell me well let's just say
that well no but let's just say this
we've got a perhaps a couple of big
things coming in to king's canyon to
start a season two okay so keep your
eyes peeled over the next month see what
you can find out so if I were to like
ask you you know after we're done with
this are you like gonna give me the cold
shoulder are you actually gonna tell me
there's no way I can tell you sorry so
man I'm holding elbows all the way out
here man this is not it's not fair well
true thank you so much Frank guys apex
legends season 2 July 2nd could not get
here soon enough now if you're in Los
Angeles come check out apex legends at
EA play for your first chance to get
hands-on with Watson as well as all the
other great apex legends things
happening here and for those of you at
home double xp weekend is going on right
now so jump it to the legendary Hunt
event and start earning those amazing
exclusive skins I'm golden boy it's been
a blast
talking apex legends with you all here
today and I'll see you in the arena
[Music]